national security team is warning that
another terrorist attack in kabul is
quote likely pentagon officials also
saying there are quote specific and
credible threats of even more attacks
around the kabul airport these warnings
come a day after a suicide bombing
killed 13 u.s service members and scores
of afghans amid that stern alert today
the airlift of remaining americans and
afghans trying to flee the country
presses on president biden maintains
that the u.s will hunt down those
responsible for the bombing
as he sticks to his self-imposed
withdrawal deadline four days away
national security correspondent jennifer
griffin joins us live from the pentagon
tonight good evening jen good evening
brett the president's national security
team told him today that u.s forces in
kabul face imminent terror threats and
it's likely to get worse in the coming
days as the military tries to meet a
tuesday deadline
bring these threats
very very specifically
virtually in real time
new details about the attack at the
kabul airport forced a pentagon
correction there was one suicide bomber
not two yesterday and no explosion at
the barron hotel a single suicide bomber
approached marines at abbey gate then
gunmen opened fire the pentagon
unwilling to blame the taliban i
understand that you're reliant on them
for protection around the airport but
are you
ruling out them being involved because
you're so dependent on the taliban right
now actually i i didn't hear general
mackenzie put it that way jenna in fact
i think the uh
in one of the questions he got and i
think it was addresses you know he said
idris asked was there a failure and the
general said of course there was a
failure somewhere obviously and in terms
of isis k
how many isis-k prisoners were left at
bagram and are believed to have been
released from the prison there and why
weren't they removed before the u.s
pulled out to some place like gitmo well
i don't know the exact number clearly
it's in the thousands
u.s officials say reports that they
shared lists of americans and afghan
allies with the taliban are incorrect
adding that in some cases to get these
afghans through a checkpoint they
provide the information and for the most
part the taliban have been letting those
people pass the notion that we are just
providing them with names upon names
of individuals who may stay behind in
afghanistan or in a way that would
expose anyone to additional risk
that is simply simply false the pentagon
also denied reports the taliban had
already entered kabul airport have the
taliban entered or taken control of any
parts of the military section of hkia
that you're aware of the taliban are not
in control of any part of hamid karzai
international airport i saw that report
too it's false
as to why the u.s didn't send those
isis-k to gitmo the answer from the
pentagon they thought the afghan
national army would watch them troops
remain on edge tonight in kabul even
after that suicide bombing yesterday 12
500 people were evacuated on 35 military
transport planes unfortunately some of
those c-17s were medevacs the 13
american heroes who were killed by that
suicide bomber brett will return home to
dover tomorrow brett
jennifer griffin live at the pentagon
jennifer thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else